today i want to talk about how i learned
french
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here and today i
want to talk about how i learned french
uh if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe you can click or tap on the
bell to get notifications and please
come and join me at link which is where
i now learn languages
so
i'm going to talk about my history of
learning french some of the things that
i learned about learning french
and
then i'm going to have a little walk
through a part of my library just to
show you some of the resources that i
have for learning french
um
so before i get into this subject
uh i wanna
digress a little bit i remember at
school i think maybe grade eight grade
seven i can't remember which year it was
we were asked to as a project to do a
scrapbook
of an imaginary trip to italy or maybe
we had the choice of countries and i
chose italy i don't remember
i wrote to the italian tourist bureau in
montreal
and they sent me just a stack of stuff
on all the different uh
provinces or whatever they what i don't
know what they're called in italy
and uh you know peru whatever it was i
can't remember campagna and perugia and
i like it like a stack they sent me and
so i went in there and i cut out the
pictures of the different churches and
the scenery and stuff and i
made this imaginary trip where i went
from
i don't know i can't remember now but
starting somewhere and going to this
place in that place and then
showing you know what i had cut out off
from these uh
tourist brochures uh pictures of uh what
were whatever were the major attractions
and i think i even read up a little bit
about the history and so forth and so on
now said not to do with french however
if at that point at school they had
introduced the italian language i would
have been interested in learning it
we never had anything attractive
presented to us about french at school
all i remember is at one point we had to
memorize the 16 verbs that take et as an
auxiliary verb so just visa you know
just
the 16 motion verbs that take et as an
auxiliary verb instead of avoir so that
was a big deal we had to and a lot of
stuff was presented to us that way you
know sort of individual snippets of
grammar
i remember we had a french teacher
maybe in grade 10 who was
from england
and when it was time to speak
french he would say all right you guys
now we're gonna talk frog language that
was really inspiring like that we all
had a good chuckle
frog language what the hell
uh then we had a teacher who was a
reverend and he would come into class
and he not only wore his you know black
thing which is whatever collar but he
had a cape
to keep the dust off his thing
and so in those days there was a very
popular tv program called zorro
and it had a theme sort of theme tuned
to it so whenever he showed up in class
we'd all start humming the theme to
zorro
uh other than that he put us to sleep
in his class so
with that uh i would say by the time i
was 16
i think all of us we had some words the
funny thing is they focused entirely on
grammar
and boring stories about some guy
traveling on a steamboat
or something like that totally
uninteresting stuff we had no choice in
terms of what might interest us in the
language
uh and at the end of it all all we could
do in montreal mind you is put words
together
like we couldn't even speak
grammatically correctly we just had
words in the end all we got was words
which is not bad because to me language
learning is all about words
so what changed what changed was that i
went to university mcgill university
uh
not knowing what to study i decided i
would study french and english
whatever literature you know they had a
these are things that were at least
familiar to me i was 16 at the time uh
we had an option in montreal we could go
to first year university or finish and
do a grade 12 at school i opted to go to
university because school was sort of
boring
and not knowing what to study i just
chose that
and we had a professor maurice rabotan
who made french civilization interesting
much like these
you know the brochures that i received
from the italian consulate in montreal
all of a sudden there were some things
that were sparkling there and there was
a book about
you know the history of france and the
different
eras and the famous painters of that era
and the famous you know whether moliere
or david and all this stuff and it was a
very nicely done book
and
i got interested
and as a result
i started you know there is a french two
french newspapers in montreal you can
start trying to pick your way through
those which i then started to do
uh
they and so everything french became
interesting french
musicians listening to them even though
i couldn't understand them you know or
watching movies like
julie jim was one of the early ones in
la nouvelle vag and so i became a bit of
a francophile
because there was something there that
was attractive
uh so now to work on my french language
the main thing was to do a lot of
reading and i'm going to show you're
going to walk through my library and
show you some of the books that i have
but i have enjoyed reading and reading
this is just so powerful
uh french
you know i think french i think for a
lot of people is harder to understand
than spanish say but even in spanish for
most people mexican spanish is easier to
understand than spanish spanish
from spain
and the reason is because it's more
sing-songy in mexico and so the more
sing-songy the language is the easier it
is to pick up where one word ends and
the next word begins well guess what
french is essentially monotonous and so
the first thing that you have to realize
which i started to realize was that
you have to start to
you know listen to how they're speaking
uh
and that's how you're gonna speak and
it's also gonna help you to understand
once your brain is used to how that
language works
and so
and another thing that i had to do is to
figure out how to pronounce
because that right off the bat is the
hardest sound in french
and one of the suggested ways of doing
that
is to say ooh which is what would be as
english speakers are default sound
and then try to say e at the same time
so i go
first you gotta be able to make the
sound and then you have to as with so
many things you have to do it on the fly
so uh
you have to be able to get that in there
in the middle of something which takes a
little more practice so
again i must admit french
and then later on mandarin chinese are
the only languages where i made any
special effort to work on pronunciation
another thing in french
which can be difficult at first and all
of these pronunciation things
impact your ability to understand and so
the listening and practice of listening
is also part of getting used to the
sounds of the language and then trying
to imitate them and then you understand
it better when you listen
so the nasal sounds you know oh
now a lot of english speakers when they
say provence which is an area of france
right they'll say provence
which is province and so you have to
make sure you get the own
oh
right so that takes a little bit of
effort
but i must say in my own case when i was
learning french
i might it's just so far back i can't
remember i might have made the special
effort to get those sounds right
uh somewhere along the line
i
focused in on the fact that again to
sound french
you got to have a lot of uh you don't
say um when you're waiting
thinking about what what you want to say
is
and the uh sound pervades french and
it's particularly important that in the
middle of a word like uh boswa
jo duvjar
uh whatever that is uh
and so many people say beswa
and not just english speakers because
there aren't many languages where e is
uh
but it is in french and it's a big part
of speaking properly and also
understanding it well
and the uh at the end of a word can be
pronounced or not pronounced so the uh
is almost like a non-sound so you can
say for example
become
the second e it you can say de vernier
but mostly it's just divnir so you get
used to this so you can like there's the
famous song by jacques
at the end you can also say no
but for the purposes of the song it's
always there as an option
whenever the uh appears at the end of a
word you can pronounce it
or not pronounce it and
for this reason the sort of you know
tying one word into the other the uh
having a few o's around make and
speaking monotonously uh makes you sound
more french
uh
what else was i going to say so that's
important oh and the other thing that
makes french hard to understand is the
liaison
again i'm sure it took me a long time
see i have no real once i got carried
away with french and wanting to hear it
and speak it and read it i have no
recollection of any specific effort that
i did to improve my french i became
aware that they have the passage samp
it's there okay you know you see it more
and more often in books you hear it
all these things just gradually sunk
into my brain as i did enough listening
and reading but at some point uh i had
to realize that you know when you say
come on tale the t come on is how. come
on televu how are you
how are you going how's it going come on
televu
you know
like uh in a you know as a taboo katamoa
in so far as i'm concerned
[Music]
this whole liaison thing where the last
consonant of a word will be pronounced
only if there's a vowel in the next word
and it almost seems to be a part of the
next word so if you say tu tafe it's tu
al
tu tafe
you know by all means tutafe it's almost
as if the
is the next word but it isn't so these
are some of the things i think that i
just started getting used to and of
course i ended up going to france
because i got so carried away with
french and france
i went to france and i studied there for
three years and you're there you're
surrounded
by the language i did all my studying in
french my hand got tired from writing
you know essays
in french turning in papers doing exams
in french reading in french and now i'm
going to end up so that's the thing so
how did i learn french i don't remember
but it all happened once i got turned
out of the language
uh and that's the way what they should
do in schools
you know the first thing they should do
is they imagine
you know an imaginary trip in quebec or
france or belgium or switzerland and go
let them go out and find what is in
those countries and the cities and the
people and the customs and the history
and whatever put together a little
scrapbook so that at least you begin by
being interested in the everything that
surrounds the language then you might
have a chance to put the effort in as i
did into letting that language wash over
you and every so often a teacher can
point out certain things in the language
that you might miss and maybe need to be
pointed out so that you start to notice
them and gradually create the right
habits so i'll end up with a little tour
of my french book section and i
apologize for the mess
i haven't cleaned up for this it's just
i thought it would be fun to show you
that okay bye for now okay so here we
are in my audiobook section
uh you see that marcel proust that was
deadly to read but when you listen to
the audiobook it's lovely
and so i have up here is our check
section but we won't go there
down here you'll see
that there's a lot of balzac and and i
like traditional
literature
and uh
down here as well it's still french
yeah i'll check in there
yeah some of the uh some of the uh
where are we here
uh that's swedish and jack and something
all right so you see a lot of
well-worn books from the leave the push
lots of balzac
what do i have here
cuisine cuisine like cooking
and then we're wandering into other
languages what do we got down here oh
this is my
portuguese
anyway you'll see that there's a lot of
books
in french so
and of course in other languages
[Music]